antoine break est avec nous et
marc-antoine le bret qui donne des
nouvelles de toutes les stars du paf du
cinéma de la bd et même à angoulême à
angoulême le festival de la bd et
j'adore et on a des nouvelles de kev
adams c'est bien madame cédait 4 17 ans
tu sais que tu as bien tu l'as bien
fraîche elle salue sérieux direct la
série soda brèche cartonne tellement
aussi n'est que maintenant pauwels et
plus soda c'est champagne laval sérieux
elle est grave bonne savard c'était
grave bonne en vagues aux siens à 8 12
alors tout cas le film piste où il
marche super bien christophe carrière
vous en pensez quoi vous c'est sûr que
j'ai pas le parent ni la liste de
schindler mais franchement c'est pas un
navet mais je voulais dire que j'ai un
petit problème avec kev adams
quand je mange et je trouve mal coiffée
j'ai un problème avec ses cheveux c'est
comme jean luc reichmann l'eau si j'ai
un problème avec les chiens alors qu'a
vécu des moments difficiles cette
semaine alors on a appris qu'ils
allaient sur rtl qui changeait de radio
son émission sur france 2 cet art et
essai c'est laurent wiki et mais petite
beauté
j'aime bien le gars le gars il m'a pris
deux mois jukebox je vais vous lire non
j'adore les imitations les moyens truc
que je préfère on fait tous les soirs
mais chéri on va regarder des images de
nous dans notre édition d'hier en train
de commenter des images de nous dans
notre édition d'hier
quand on se regarde et à 3 jours en
train de mater néji marchent debout il
ya 4
alors comment lancer mais donc laurent
qui viendra pas soir bonsoir c'est
l'histoire à tous vos chroniques la
peinture ici à propos de la quotidienne
de l'émission pour tous
je dois reconnaître que vraiment j'ai
fait une erreur au niveau du titre
j'aurais dû directement la paix
l'émission pour personne oui non oui oui
l'or
oui oui on aimerait bien avoir des
nouvelles je leur parlais tout à l'heure
des émissions de cuisine le la star pour
voir des émissions de cuisine ça reste
quand même si la ligne atteint 100 des
séries c'est cyril je voulais dire à
jean-michel cohen que j'ai trouvé un
super moyen de faire un métier ça fait
grossir les jambes
ouais j'suis à manger qu'elle a vu les
causes a été les spectateurs il veut pas
manger les plats et même si si bien
gourmand bien des microcars personnes
gros si vous dire qu'avec des émissions
que j'ai fait la seule chose qui grossit
j'ai mon compte en banque
alors est survenue de sotchi adelson
monfort et philippe candeloro
alors que des grands penseurs serrer la
alors vous savez sans doute que le csa
nous a quelque peu vilipendé pour al
sadd six cas il ya quelques bien sûr
quelques temps mais cela n'est pas notre
préoccupation majeure quand nous
revenons les jeux paralympiques conte
qui est touchée par ces athlètes
admirable qui lutte avec dignité contre
le handicap à mon cher philippe
candeloro tu as raison des sommes
seraient que les handicapés c'est des
gens comme les autres
je peux vous dire que les petites
patineuse paralympiques
elle doit avoir quelques membres en moi
j'ai déglingue quand même pacifique
c'est ça ta car si ce sera ici c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui comme hier c'était
en tout cas on termine tout est prévu à
bercy par caen
plus la première fois qu il est avec
nous tous les vendredis